Let's look at an example.
Here I'm initializing
an NSArray of strings.
Notice that if I look for
the method addObject or
something akin to Swift's append method,
it's not found.
In fact, if you search
the NSArray class reference,
you won't find any methods for
adding objects to the array.
I can make a new array using
the array by adding object method but
I can't add an object to
an existing NSAarray.
The other option is to define my
array as an NSMutableArray and
now we can see that the method
add object is indeed available to
an NSMutableArray and
we can add booties to our kayaking gear.
We'll go ahead and run it.
We can look down here in the console and
see the contents of our array.
Swift and Objective C differ in their
use of reference types and value types.
Swift encourages widespread
use of value types like strut
while Objective C favors
reference types like classes.
Structs are used pretty
sparingly in Objective C and
they don't have the capability
that struts do in Swift swift.
For example, this beer struck on the
left that we've seen before in swift on
the left would be encoded as a class and
objective C.
To understand what this means for
immutability, let's compare what happens
when a type is copied by value and
what happens when an object
is copied by reference.
This comparison will likely
be familiar to you by now.
Focus on the last four lines of code and
take a few seconds to guess
the value of myBeer.style.
Down here in the console,
we can see that myBeer is still a lager.
Structs are value types.
When myBeer was assigned to yourBeer,
a new copy was made, and
the values of the two
copies are independent.
Let's see what happens when beer is
implemented as a class in Objective C.
Now focus on these four lines of code,
and
again try to guess
the value of myBeer.style.
We'll run the project, and
down here in the console we see that
the style of myBeer is now a stout.
Classes are reference types,
which means that when we assigned myBeer
to yourBeer, a new reference was made.
But myBeer and yourBeer both point
to the same underlying instance.
When we changed the value
of yourBeer.style,
we changed the value of the underlying
instance to which both beers refer.